d'une part les états unis ne démentant
le démonter leur ont jamais leurs gars
fassent ça me semble une évidence
et puis ensuite mettons que l'europe
décide de démanteler localement par une
astuce quelconque
de toute façon quel serait le plan b à
google à facebook
on en a strictement aucun et vous voulez
bloquer tout à l'heure aujourd'hui on
n'a pas de champions européens et c'est
absolument illusoire de croire qu'on en
aura un
on a pris un tel retard qu'il faudrait
une génération et des milliers de
milliards d'investissements pour arriver
à faire éclore un big tech de cette
envergure
donc on a un vrai sujet qui est un sujet
de souveraineté d'une part et qui est un
sujet de manque de vision politique et
de politiques industrielles numériques
spécifiquement et aujourd'hui on n'a
aucune vision de ce point de vue là
alors qu'on pourrait typiquement la
france à des actifs stratégiques dans la
biotech dans la défense dans
l'aérospatiale et pourtant on continue à
saupoudrer quelques millions à droite à
gauche sur une french tech illusoire
plutôt cadors d'avoir des choix optimaux
radicaux en termes de politique
industrielle vous dit il n'y a pas de
plan b européen il ya le projet gaia x
le projet franco-allemand vous n'y
croyez pas du tout le projet alors c'est
une initiative s'est pas vraiment projet
et c'est un peu comme le col for good in
tech se sont encore une fois un peu
comme l'axé tic plein de bonnes
intentions incantatoire aujourd'hui les
cloud qui fonctionne hyper bien qu'ils
sont très rapides sont aujourd'hui des
cloud américain et un moment donné on a
eu au vh qui a eu qui a eu toutes eu
toute une posture cet été pendant le
scandale duel data robe qui avait été
qui avait été
donner à microsoft en dix ans mais nous
on est un acteur français souverains de
cloud plutôt efficace
et qu'est ce qu'on voit à la rentrée en
fait qu'il vient de faire un partenariat
avec google
donc bon les solutions de cloud
souverain aujourd'hui où en europe est
en tout cas on n'y est pas encore où on
en est encore vraiment au stade disons
incantatoire
[Musique]